el lunes al presidente de Estados Unidos
Joe biden le dio luz verde al
controvertido proyecto denominado Willow
para aumentar la extracción de petróleo
en Alaska La representante demócrata en
Alaska defendió la medida alegando
beneficios financieros
hice campaña a favor de Willow porque
sabía que lo necesitábamos debemos
invertir el declive económico de Alaska
hoy la administración biden ha tomado la
decisión correcta y antepuesto el
progreso energético real al absolutismo
Willow será ejecutado por el gigante
petrolero conozco Phillips y estiman que
producirá 180.000 barriles por día
ayudará a crear 250.000 empleos y miles
de millones de dólares sin embargo los
ecologistas mostraron oposición y
acusaron a biden de romper sus promesas
sobre la lucha contra el cambio
climático
tratando de apaciguar a la delegación
que haya sus compinches de los
combustibles fósiles en el congreso Y
eso es increíblemente decepcionante de
ver
dice que no solo se preocupa por la
crisis climática sino también por
abordar a la justicia ambiental y
abordar la crisis de extinción y sin
embargo este proyecto exacerbará las
tres crisis
en la misma jornada el gobierno
estadounidense amplió protecciones en
tierras y aguas de Alaska y el mar
Ártico pero los ambientalistas critican
la ambigüedad y prometen una lucha
judicial tras una nueva decepción en
materia ecológica el senador de Alaska
dan Sullivan dijo que la delegación del
Congreso aguarda un desafío legal
inminente y prepara un informe para
defender el proyecto petrolero